Vladimir Putin has been in power for a
really long time over two decades he's
faced many challenges while building up
power at home and growing his country's
influence on the global stage but
coronavirus could be his biggest test
yet the film despite his reassurances
that everything was fine Russia has
become a global coronavirus hotspot and
its infrastructure has come under strain
Russians worry the pandemic will worsen
their economic problems and now as
constitutional changes could potentially
allow Putin to remain in office until
2036 the president has to deal with
unexpectedly low approval ratings it's
the lowest speed in 20 years since he
first came to power
so can the Russian president actually
keep all the power he's accumulated
Vladimir Putin has served as either
prime minister or President of Russia
since 1999 the former intelligence
officer has fought to change the image
of a crumbling Russian state so the
framework that person came on was very
much to try to rise and really old
Russia's position as a great power early
in his tenure he faced a number of
crises a few weeks into his time as
Acting Prime Minister a series of
bombings in Moscow killed hundreds
triggering a second chechen war which
this time Russia won
the military offensive boosted Putin's
popularity and helped him secure the
presidency in 2014 has nurtured this
image of himself a tough statesman who
restored the country's national pride
Putin's boldness fostered nationalism
and kept him popular in Russia but
strained his relationship with Western
leaders
he poured resources into the military
and made it a tool for his foreign
policy which caught international
attention in the Russell Georgian war in
2008 2008 marked a change or in the way
that Russian great power Nets were going
to be implemented and increasingly it is
implemented using the military on the
ground when Putin's opponents took to
the streets after he was elected again
in 2012 Russian officials accused the
u.s. of instigating the demonstrations
politically it is the new Tristram II it
was known as the stage that do myself of
course the u.s. denied it couldn't
believe that all those people out on the
streets were there of their own volition
so it was much easier for him to blame
the US the West hundreds were arrested
and protests waned after the government
imposed new rules on public
demonstrations the annexation of Crimea
and Putin's support for the regime of
Bashar al-assad in Syria added to
international tensions Moscow has also
been accused of meddling in the 2016 US
election among other allegations
including state backed disinformation
and hacking Russia has repeatedly
rejected these claims listen to what I
say first of all Russia as a state has
never interfered with the internal
affairs of the United States but the
corona virus pandemic has introduced a
whole new challenge for the 67 year old
leader when corona virus infections
began to ramp up in Russia Putin closed
its border with China and implemented
restrictions on travel from Europe but
he was criticized for not imposing a
strict nationwide lockdown
co-owner when you've left at about 2:00
it hit Michener our venues or now while
the president and state media insisted
that everything was under control some
officials contradicted the government's
narrative in May the health minister of
Dagestan suggested in an interview that
the real number of coronavirus cases in
his province could have been more than
four times higher than the official
figures forcing Putin to acknowledge
that the virus was an issue in some
parts of the country of the disdaining
the Gastonia suit was just a poster
medical personnel have taken to social
media to criticise the government's
handling of the pandemic and warn that
the healthcare infrastructure was
overwhelmed but Putin and Russia's
national media outlets have persisted in
painting a more positive picture
problemo very party area most sure to
give me the status nur technician
attacks Cara bottom II of holding mr.
versus Cara natterson
smile imitating me even as the collapse
in oil prices was hitting Russia's
economy hard Moscow trumpeted efforts to
send medical aid to Italy and the US and
in late June ahead of a referendum that
may allow Putin to run for two more
terms after his tenure ends in 2024
soldiers marched in a parade to
celebrate the country's victory over
Germany in World War two despite
concerns that the virus may spread sort
of boost the nationalist pride in saying
we were solely responsible for this
victory and and this is what makes us a
great power as part of the referendum
the Russian president has also offered a
number of measures to support the
economy still his popularity has waned
in recent months in a recent poll only
25 percent of Russians named Putin among
the politicians they trust most down
from 59% in 2017 the economy has
contracted and the pandemic has grown to
become an unexpected challenge for
Russia's government but
analysts believe that Vladimir Putin is
determined to hold on to power he's
still solidly in power that I think
there are many more questions about what
happens going forward and about you know
his willingness and ability to introduce
economic reforms that would make
people's lives better